welcome back safety blitz it is time for
turn the page tuesday ride this is where
we look at those teams where maybe
wasn't so positive they got something
they need to flip the script on the
baltimore ravens defensively picked
apart by the bangles what pages do they
need to turn if you will i'm looking at
the ravens defense and they played and
did an excellent job against the
chargers a couple weeks ago and held
justin herbert to 195 yards passing and
one interception they were after him
they hit him they confused them and then
two weeks later they come and play
against the second year quarterback joe
burrow and look absolutely the complete
opposite and that's it's just like how
does that happen how do you not come
with the same focus you know you're
playing against
some great talented young players and
you know the cincinnati bengals are
hungry so you got to bring it every
single week if you're the baltimore
ravens defense
you know what i think it is i think that
there is not a level of respect in the
afc north for the bengals i just don't
believe that there is a level of respect
now there will be i think it's
developing
be honest with you i think it's here
they go into pittsburgh and they just
hammered the steelers now they go into
baltimore and they destroy the ravens so
it's here now make no mistake the
respect is there but i just think that
going into that game there's there's
still a little bit of snoozing going on
there's a little bit of they just don't
see it yet now they're starting to feel
it right but if you give me running back
three wide receivers tight end and
quarterback all of those positions i
don't know of a team or an offense that
i'm taking over cincinnati's right now i
don't know of anybody that has skill
positions in the quarterback combo
that's better and this dude borough
reminds me so much and i've been saying
it for two years now the mind the way he
carries himself his accuracy he reminds
me so much of the way that tom brady
reads the defense he loves to play from
empty just like tom does loves to use
the run game play the play action just
the confidence the way he stands tall
back there he reminds me so much of
brady man and with those weapons i just
think this is less about baltimore's
defense and more about the fact that we
are seeing one of the premier offenses
in all football develop in front of our
eyes right now and believe it or not
it's right here in cincinnati i almost
can't believe i'm saying it see the one
thing i'm i'm a little disappointed in
you because you sit back and you give
all the players credit all the players
credit but you won't take 20 seconds to
give zach taylor he's the head coach but
a guy like you from cincinnati you would
kill him last year but you won't even
give him credit and you have the
platform right now to give him credit so
i'm sitting here listening i want to see
you give zach taylor who who deserves
credit because right now who's the coach
of the year you tell me who's the coach
of the year other than zach taylor
it would have to be taylor i think the
only one you could throw up there may be
a staley with the chargers that may be
the other one maybe maybe mccarthy with
the with the dallas cowboys cliff
kingsbury you just threw in the mix
yeah that's a good one that's a good one
too but above them all right now i think
you probably would go from how ugly it
was to how good it's become first place
in the whole afc
he's got to be right up there you know
what was crazy rod is we had him on the
podcast joe burrow on the podcast this
offseason and they asked him about zach
taylor and i didn't really know what his
temperature would be on him and he raved
i mean he went on for 20 minutes and he
could have just given a positive answer
about him but i mean he went on and on
and on about how he trusts him how he
asks him questions how he's always
calling the offense specific to what he
likes and loves and the players he wants
to get the ball to i was going
god burro feels that highly about him
and i know how they feel about burrow
this coach must be the real deal and
it's played out just like that this
season so it's been really cool to watch
see
a great point too jack those are
conversations that's that happens on the
practice field behind the scenes that we
don't we don't see so
you know the fact that you said that was
great because it points out him coaching
him having those conversations him
communicating with his quarterback those
are the conversations that fans don't
see and that's why i said it's zach
taylor because when you're quarterback
you're a young quarterback who's
remember he's coming off a acl
and it's not like he's a hundred percent
because typically and this is the point
that nobody's making typically i've had
acl it takes two years to feel like
yourself this guy's come back less than
two years and he's playing phenomenal
he's playing phenomenal football so he's
only going to get better the more
comfortable he feels with his knee
because a lot of times you come off that
acl
your knee doesn't feel like it's there
you don't feel like it's there so you
don't have a lot of confidence and he's
moving around fine but you give him
another six to eight months man and he's
on i mean another you know just give him
more time he's going to continue to get
healthy
yeah i mean even the fact that he was
able to play week one like everyone's
like even people in cincinnati like whoa
like let's maybe wait till week three
week four give him an extra month to get
healthy and joe was like forget all that
i'm playing week one it's for him to be
playing like this man that's crazy
watching kansas city talk about flipping
the page this is just the opposite side
of all of it right the kansas city
chiefs coming into this season they're
all the buzz all the hype mahomes is
going to be healthy it's not going to be
the beat up the homes that we saw in the
super bowl the chiefs are going to be
back
the chiefs are not back the chiefs have
been disgustingly horrible this season
and it probably came to the peak of the
mountain against the titans they look
terrible
yeah we get a chance to see the type of
leadership and the type of character
guys that they have in their locker room
but it all started in the off season
when patrick mahomes and he was guilty
of it he was the one talking about being
20-0 and you know being undefeated all
these guys go out and they get paid he
gets 400 million chris jones gets 100
million and you just don't see the same
hunger you don't see the same effort in
2019 when they won the super bowl you
don't see that when you put on the tape
you don't see those guys flying around
sacrificing for each other jumping over
piles just doing every single thing to
win look at them they're not even
hustling the offensive line is just
jogging and that's what happens when you
get new guys that come to a new um
system they okay we can just show up
they got it all taken care of we got
patrick mahomes no
buffalo you're standing in the way of
buffalo baltimore all these teams the
chargers
trying to get to the super bowl so these
guys are coming with a singular focus
they're trying to beat you they're
giving you everything they've got and
everything that they've done for their
team is trying to beat you whether it's
picking up defensive guys look at the
charges they went out and got the the
defensive coordinator of the number one
defense in the national football league
last year to be their head coach to come
in and influence their defense that's
how important it is for them to you know
to be able to stop and compete against
kansas city
it was 27 to nothing at halftime this
game 27 to nothing at halftime and if
you watch it it's not like fluky stuff
it is just the tennessee titans just
hammered them in every which way kansas
city's defense they can't stop the run
they can't stop the pass they look soft
they look horrible it's just sloppy
football i mean it's even when they
blitz they're not getting there and
there's wide open guys on the back end
it just looks bad when you watch the
chief's offense
they're not they're not hungry i see my
homes talking to the ref more than i've
ever seen him he's like complaining
about stuff if people hit him he's like
he can't wait to go chirp to the ref
it's like well when did he become mr
superstar in homes this used to be a
different kind of young cat you know i
mean this was a guy that was like always
playing on his toes and hungry and i
never saw that stuff from the homes even
when he took off and ran in this first
half and it was a positive play we just
showed the highlight he's carrying the
football like he's gonna throw it when
he's 15 yards down the field he fumbles
it and gives it right back to tennessee
they go right back down for a touchdown
so it's just this sloppy football stuff
and and i see him less confident in
making those superhero plays now that
the interceptions are there i just don't
see him having that you know outworldly
that confidence that seemed to come from
outer space it was like we hadn't really
seen it on an nfl field before he
doesn't play with that confidence
anymore it just looks like he's made
mistakes now he's holding the football
for a long long time and he's getting
hit really hard this chief's team looks
night and day different to me night and
day
that that's the point that you made he's
finally getting hit and um i had some
defensive players tell me simon what's
what you think about my homes now he
said man we're so upset about homes
because what kansas city tries to do
they try they don't just try to beat you
they absolutely try to embarrass you and
they sit there and they laugh and he
these defensive players told me said man
we're doing everything we can to beat
these guys to play physical with him to
hit him because it's embarrassing as a
team you're going out there he's
flipping no look passes he's throwing
sidearm he's doing all these crazy
things it's embarrassing so these guys
understand it
kansas city's offense is trying to
embarrass them so they come with a
different mindset and you see it man
every single time they get an
opportunity they're they're punishing
patrick mahomes now he finally gets to
see that the nfl isn't as easy as he
thought it was i mean he's a super
talented kid he's going to bounce back i
do believe they're gonna bounce back and
they're gonna be right there fighting
for that seven sixth position in the afc
but at the end of the day man it was a
lot it's humble pie going on that's what
we called it when i played kansas city
getting a nice large piece of humble pie
and they they really deserve it
they needed it they needed it now it's a
matter of can they can they come up with
answers to this test because we were
saying for a while now we've been saying
it for a month plus there's a whole new
book out there's a whole new defensive
strategy to play in these guys rod
playing all these two deep safeties and
everybody's doing the same thing and
they're getting pressure on the homes
with four because he's holding the ball
for four seconds i mean he's just
holding the ball forever and he's
getting hit and he's trying to throw it
to receivers who are double covered and
stuff it just looks weird when you when
you watch the chief's offense without
the big play it really does look strange
let's get to our third turn the page
it's kind of a fun one mike evans he's
catches this touchdown it's the 600th
touchdown from brady and what's he do
going up there into the stands you see
this moment rod what the hell was this
i actually did and i'm saying like what
the heck is mike evans doing i'm like
that's tom's ball don't get that ball up
you know how much money that ball is
worth like dude if i had that ball i
could
retire i could retire but i'm glad the
fan gave it back
look at my
[Laughter]
and let me tell you something if rob
gronkowski if he was healthy you know
tom brady would have definitely thrown
that ball to him
look
look at the compensation though look at
the compensation i was loving so tom
went on last night with payton that he
did the uh whatever the heck they call
that thing peyton and eli broadcast on
espen espn2 and i was tuning in because
i was enjoying it but look what he did
he basically like break you know
peyton's going dude you gave up he gave
up the fan gave up all his leverage when
he handed the football back and that is
true i mean i think he could have been
sitting up watching the rest of the
season with gisele but instead he gets a
bitcoin worth an estimated 61
grand you get all the tickets you get
the thousand dollar credit you get to
this you get to that but the 61 grand
with the bitcoin that sounds pretty
sweet man that could go up in value too
bitcoin's hot [ __ ] do what you do
and what you do is you just you just
give that to your kid and forget about
it
right so in 30 years it might be worth a
million bucks it might be worth 2
million you just give it to your kid you
don't even touch it you just put it away
for your kid
it could be worth more than that it
could be worth even more than that hey
speaking of money rod i i forgot to do
this because i told you i had a great
story up top now i actually want to
circle back for it right we'll take a
break right after this but this story is
pretty entertaining so i'll cut it down
i look at my gas tank and i'm going i
got zero
gas i'm not going to make it in to do
the show with rod so i pull off into
this this gas station and this thing is
as packed as any gas station i've ever
been to in my life right and i'm sort of
just finding my way in between about
nine cars i put the thing in my car i'm
putting the gas in
and i decide i gotta go i'd run out of
time i got to take this thing out i got
about 50 bucks worth of gas in the tank
it's plenty right so i pull so i go to
pull this thing out you know how they
can lock how that little gas thing can
you know you need the trigger to kind of
come it locks up tight rod i got a
squirt gun i'm just squirting cash all
over the entire gas station every car
it's bouncing off my car i got it on my
clothes i've been huffing gasoline ever
since this thing i mean people were
getting out red solo cups just trying to
get a little bit of my gas i'm just
spraying it everywhere i must have
sprayed 50 bucks worth of gasoline all
over cincinnati ohio tonight
well don't lie to me
[Laughter]
hey man thank you thank you for the kids
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports